[Music]  i never  fit in  [Music]  never could win this isn't the life you  wanted  [Music]  i fell in love with country music when i  was a little girl when you let me hear  you play  [Music]  i received another letter  immigration and customs enforcement we  have a ward to search does anyone else  here reside with you is there anyone who  lives here  no no one resides with you no other  [Music]  residents  [Music]  they take everything away i don't even  have a name anymore  [Music]  we already have one daughter we don't  need another freedom away  no i want to go quietly into  the night and i'll sing to the light of  day  no i won't go quietly into the night and  i sing today  [Music]  you